zeke yeager was born to grisha yeager
and dina fritz
who were planning to overthrow the
marley government and
put the eldians back in power grisha was
among the rebels when the marley
government
announced the warrior program asking for
eldean children
between the ages of five to seven to
serve as potential warriors
with the promise that their families
would be given the title of honorary
marlians
and be insured freedom within the
country
grisha then decided to enter zeke into
the program
to play the role of a spy for his cause
at home
zeke was routinely sent to his
grandparents while both dina
and grisha attended eldian
restorationist meeting with most of his
visits
being spent listening to his grandfather
recounting the stories of the eldian
racist crimes against the world
over time his parents preoccupation with
the eldian restorationists
led them growing continuously distant
with zeke with grisha in particular
showing very little investment in his
son's life outside of his studies
and performances as a warrior candidate
initially
zeke did not perform impressively as a
warrior candidate and his trouble
keeping pace with his fellow candidates
caused him to be ostracized by his peers
and his instructor
however he did manage to make one friend
during his training
tom saver after a day of routine
training zeke happened to meet saver
while the man was in the middle of
playing catch by himself after some
prodding from saver
zeke joined him in the game and was
thrilled to hear saver complimenting him
on his pitching skill
after returning home zeke tried to tell
his parents about the experience
but found them in the middle of a
meeting with a fellow restorationist
zeke tried eavesdropping on the
conversation and listening in
as his parents reassured grice that he
had the ability to save eldia
during another public training event
zeke was once again
outperformed by all of the other
candidates to his distress
zeke observed that both his parents had
come to watch and was dismayed to see
his father storm away from the field in
frustration
that night he cried in his room while
listening to his parents argue over what
to do about his poor performance
after the training event saver tried to
cheer him up during one of their games
of catch
before joking that zeke becoming a
warrior would be a dumb idea
surprised to hear a warrior slandering
the warrior program
zeke asked to know why sabre had chosen
to become one saver's explanation
that he had wanted the opportunity to
study the titans scientifically
surprised zeke but he agreed with
sabre's assertion that neither of them
were meant to be soldiers
while cleaning the halls of the warriors
headquarters zeke overheard that the
marlene authorities were close to
discovering the location of the eldian
restorationists
knowing that this would sentence his
entire family and himself
to the border of paradise to be
converted to pure titans zeke went to
his parents and begged them to stop
but was met only with their insistence
that what they were doing
needed to be done for the good of all
eldians in a desperate attempt to appeal
to his father
zeke reminded him of fey and asked if he
would be okay
with his own son meeting the same fate
this only managed to enrage grisha
terrified zeke tried to remind his
parents that their whole family would be
sent to paradise if they were discovered
but grisha
reiterated his previous statement that
they needed to win back the rights
that marley had taken in order to make
sure that no one else met the same fate
as fae
with no one else to turn to zeke
revealed everything to save her
although zeke had resigned himself to
being sent to paradise and spent in
eternity as a titan
saver suggested that he turn in his
parents so that only they would be
punished
this would allow zeke and his
grandparents to go free zeke initially
protested the idea
but saver insisted that there was no
other way reminding zeke of all the
turmoil and strife he had experienced on
account of his parents forcing their
ideas on him without thought for his own
feelings
after some thought zeke agreed and
turned in his parents
to secure his status in marley's eyes as
a loyal warrior
soon after grisha and dina were sent to
paradise island to be transformed into
pure titans still not knowing the truth
of zeke's heritage
marley sent him to be raised by his
grandparents zeke continued his parents
cause
by operating from the shadows to secure
the aldian's freedom from marley
in his own way zeke continued playing
catch with saber regularly
during his time in the warrior program
often using the games as a time to have
long discussions with him
during one such game sabre revealed that
the founding titan
had the power to not only affect the
memories of subjects of ymir
but also change the composition of their
bodies inspired by this
zeke theorized that a holder of the
founding titan might be able to use it
to render all subjects of ymir sterile
so that they would die out within a
hundred years without a need for mass
genocide
noticing saver not immediately tossing
back the baseball
zeker's saver reveal that he once had a
family with a marlene woman who had
killed herself
after learning he was an aldian
listening to his mentor
lament his own birth zeke vowed to save
savor that he would take back the
founding titan from paradise
and keep it out of marley's hands to
ensure that it could not be used to hurt
anyone
again soon after zeke was told that the
key in the planned euthanasia of the
aldians the founding titan must be in
possession of
someone who will agree to the plan and
be in physical contact with a titan
descended from the royal family
saber asks zeke to find someone who is
willing to go through with the plan
at the age of 17 zeke became the eldest
of the warrior candidates to be selected
to receive the power of the titans
inheriting the beast titan from saver in
the year 842.
zeke kept savers glasses after
inheriting his titan as a memento of his
former friend
one year after inheriting the beast
titan zeke and his fellow warriors used
their titan forms to crush an entire
nation
zeke used his beast titan to bombard
enemies in the midst of retreat
with explosive ammunition with the
battle being a large success
the marlene army regarded the new
warriors as more effective than their
predecessors
it was decided that zeke could be kept
in marley alongside pique
as deterred to enemy nations while the
other warriors
reiner bertolt annie and marcel
were entrusted to take part in the
journey to paradise
five years after the start of the
paradise island operation
zeke travels with peak and a small
number of marlene soldiers to paradise
island
to infiltrate the walls after arriving
the group locates a small village
inside of walrose and chooses to turn
its residents into titans
the soldiers release a gas laced with
zeke's spinal fluid into the air
which is blown into the village and
inhaled by the villagers
zeke then lets out a scream triggering
all the affected eldians to begin
transforming into titans
as zeke proceeds further into wald rose
he is spotted by mike
zacharias who instantly notes the
strangeness of his characteristics and
mistakes him for a regular abnormal
as mike's horse races back to him zeke
notices it
and throws it at mike preventing the
latter from escaping
and causing him to lose his footing and
fall into the mouth of one of zeke's
titans
before the titan can devour mike zeke
orders it to refrain from eating
intent on questioning the soldier about
his vertical maneuvering equipment
the titan disobeys zeke and continues to
try to eat mike
prompting zeke to crush its head he then
proceeds to interrogate mike
but quickly gives up when the man
neglects or respond out of shock
zeke assumes that they either do not
speak the same language
or mike is too frightened to respond to
him and instead
notes that mike uses swords indicating
that the soldiers of the walls are aware
that the nape is the titan's weakness he
removes mike's equipment for a further
inspection
and takes his leave as he is leaving
zeke hears mike's cries of defiance
and allows the surrounding titans to
devour him as mike screams
in horror and pain zeke notes that they
spoke the same language
after all zeke is later seen wandering
around outside
garden castle where several members of
the survey corps have been trapped by
his titans
as his titans surround the castle zeke
climbs up wall rose
and watches the ensuing battle after the
soldiers kill most of the larger titans
zeke begins throwing large stones at the
tower killing lin
henning and the soldier's remaining
horses he then screams
summoning more titans to continue the
assaults on the castle
afterwards zeke climbs over the wall and
disappears into the lost territory
of walmaria at the time historia rhys
is crowned queen roughly two months
after both reiner and bertolt
were exposed as traitors and escaped the
survey corps zeke is reunited with the
two warriors
he learns from them that marcel has been
eaten shortly after arriving on the
island and annie
has been captured by the military
however bertolt and reiner reveal that
they have discovered the identity of the
person in possession of the founding
titan one of their former comrades in
the survey corps
named aaron yeager stunned to learn that
aaron is his younger half-brother
along with the fact that grisha somehow
managed to survive and avoid getting
turned into a titan
zeke breaks down in anguish that evening
in addition
zeke contemplates how aaron despite not
possessing royal blood
managed to use the powers of the
founding titan
certain that aaron is the person that he
has been searching for to make his plan
succeed
zeke makes acquiring his half-brother
the top priority of the warriors
when he informs both reiner and bertolt
about this they protest
and insist the recovery of annie takes
precedence over capturing aaron
eventually reiner decides to challenge
zeke to a battle
with their respective titan forms but
zeke swiftly and
effortlessly defeats him while bertolt
takes reiner's body from his titan form
ziki merges and proclaims himself the
winner he then tells the two of them
that they can rescue annie
after securing the founding titan
informing them of his plan to wait in
shiganshina to ambush the survey corps
sometime after zeke's disagreement with
reiner and bertolt
he reminds them not to worry about annie
pointing out that the survey corps would
not be able to torture her without
triggering her titan abilities and
theorizing that she is likely only in
hiding
noting their dissatisfaction he
questions whether they have lost their
resolve
he offers to fight reiner again to
decide what they will do next
but threatens to feed him to another
warrior if he loses again
peak arrives shortly afterwards to
inform them of the survey corps's
imminent arrival
and the three proceed to their post to
prepare for the upcoming battle
before they go both reiner and bertolt
warned zeke about a man named
levi intrigued zeke acknowledges his
subordinates concerns
but internally disregards the soldier as
being a threat to him
soon after the survey corps initiate the
operation to retake walmaria
after aaron manages to seal the outer
gate of shiganshina
zeke reiner and bertolt launch their
operation
after reiner's failed attack and his
momentary downfall
zeke transforms alongside with a
numerous horde of titans
outside the wall zeke immediately picks
up a giant boulder and launches it
at the inner gate destroying it so that
the soldier's horses will not get over
it
and effectively cutting off their only
escape route from the battle
back to shigan china zeke then starts
walking slowly towards the city with a
maniacal grin on his face
as he advances he roars ordering smaller
titans to attack the survey core's
horses
while having the larger titans form a
circle around the entrance of
shiganshina district in order to prevent
the soldiers from escaping
after some time zeke receives a signal
to throw a barrel containing bertolt
into shiganshina
in the form of a roar from reiner's
titan form after sending bertolt over
the wall
zeke begins attacking the survey corps
north of the district with a barrage of
stones pretending that he is pitching
baseballs in order to help himself aim
each throw breaks the sound barrier and
every soldier who is caught in the
barrage is utterly vaporized
forcing levi and the rest of the
soldiers to retreat to the base of the
wall
as he continues his assault zeke notices
a large group of soldiers
led by irwin smith riding towards him
zeke states that he had expected a
better counter-attack than a suicide run
as his pitches hit their mark zeke
laments the fact that king fritz erased
the soldiers memories of the world
forcing them to keep making the same
mistakes and push themselves to die
honorably
as a result of their ignorance getting
worked up at the thought
zeke accidentally crushes the stones in
his hand into dust
and is forced to calm himself down for a
moment before resuming his attack
killing many more soldiers zeke notices
that there are some still alive
despite the odds and continue their
charge seeing their persistence
causes him to become annoyed again
opining that they can shoot smoke at him
all day long
as it will not achieve anything as he
finishes off the stragglers with one
final throw
the zeke begins to lament their deaths
before noticing with alarm
that the titans flanking him have been
killed bewildered as to what happened he
is suddenly ambushed by levi who slices
his arm to pieces
as he attempts to grab him realizing
that he is facing the soldier that
reiner and bertolt warned him about
zeke tries to guard his nape but is
immediately blinded by levi
before zeke can react to being blinded
his titan's achilles tendons are slashed
leaving him unable to stand
realizing that there is no time to
harden this nape zeke tries to use his
hand to shield it
but it is immediately cut to pieces as
well as levi begins to cut open his nape
zeke emerges from his titan trying to
use the steam emitted to blind levi
but is immediately skewered through his
mouth by the captain
before levi can execute zeke peak
rescues him and carries him away from
the battlefield
as they flee zeke orders his remaining
titans to kill levi
pete carries zeke back to shiganshina
where he locates and approaches aaron
who is holding bertolt hostage
zeke recognizes him as his half-brother
and tries to talk aaron down claiming
that they are both victims of their
father
aaron is shocked by zeke's resemblance
to grisha
but before zeke can further elaborate he
is forced to retreat
due to the arrival of levi whose sudden
appearance takes zeke by surprise
as he takes his leave he apologizes to
bertolt
stating that he will not be able to save
him before promising aaron that he will
come back and save
him while escaping zeke and peak locate
a severely injured rhino
rescuing him from the remaining survey
corps soldiers who have captured him
shortly after the battle of shiganshina
district the marley mideast war began
in secret zeke sends his group of
followers the anti-marlene volunteers
to paradise island to make contact with
the aldians living there
zeke also gives the volunteers a list of
requirements that paradise island would
need to fulfill
in exchange for his aid zeke also
arranged the marlene survey ships to
carry large stalks of wine
mixed with the spinal fluid this wine
would be served to members of the
military
starting with the high-ranking officers
the zeke would also make contact with
kiyomi azumabito
from the nation of hizuru on the
possibility of forming an alliance with
paradise
he acknowledges what he did to his
parents and reveals that marley
does not know what a titan with royal
blood can do when joined with the
founding titan
as a token of goodwill zeke brings out
the vertical maneuvering equipment
he took from mike zacharias and presents
it to her
he mentions the existence of iceberg
stone which powers the device
and there are scant traces still inside
at some point during the war
it was decided that warrior candidate
colt greis would become the one to
inherit zeke's beast titan at the end of
zeke's term
at the climax of the war zeke takes part
in the assault on fort slava
as eldean captives parachute down from
an airship zeke uses his royal blood
powers
to transform the captives into titans
inflicting a devastating airstrike upon
fort slava
after the armored titan destroys the
anti-titan artillery
zeke transforms into the beast titan and
joins the battle
using leftover artillery rounds as
projectiles he destroys
the mid-east allied force's fleet the
fleet themselves
fire upon zeke before their destruction
but reiner's armored titan save zeke
being destroyed in the process after the
conclusion of the battle
zeke takes part in a meeting with marley
officials to discuss the war's
conclusion
and marley's future zeke suggests
resuming the paradise island operation
to retake the founding titan as soon as
possible when reminded that marley
cannot rely entirely on titans anymore
zeke mentions that marley can also use
this time to improve their own military
ordinance for their ground troops while
they seek out the founding titan on
paradise island
after the meeting zeke speaks with colt
about his powers as the beast titan
colt unaware along with the rest of
marley about the properties of zeke's
royal blood
calls him special zeke feigns ignorance
over the reasons behind his powers
but promises that colt will know his
secrets after inheriting his titan
commander magath joins the conversation
and they discuss the 32 survey ships
that have disappeared when sent to
paradise island zeke speculates that
paradise island has control over four
titans
and at least two of them were
responsible for the disappearance of the
32 survey ships
zeke informs magath of the anti-titan
weaponry
as well as the existence of the ackerman
clan and says
underestimating these factors were what
led to his defeat
zeke departs on a train to liberia after
the train arrives
zeke walks with the warrior forces into
the internment zone
when he arrives he is lovingly welcomed
by his grandparents
zeke later holds an unofficial meeting
attended by his fellow warriors and cult
he speaks about the world's growing
animosity towards eldians
as well as the future in which
conventional weaponry will eclipse
tighten weaponry he also expresses worry
for the future of the eldian race
for these reasons zeke states that to
solve these concerns
marley must continue with the plan to
regain the founder
with the prestigious tiber family
narrating the warriors plans to the
world
giving the eldians within marley an
extent of clout
these points are debated among the
warriors with him
in peak staying on the same wavelength
throughout the unofficial meeting had
been tapped by marlene authorities
with zeke seemingly aware of this fact
along with the warriors
zeke attends a meeting with his
superiors where they explain their plans
for the new operation on paradise island
later as colt states his brother does
not need to become a warrior
zeke calls him to order but quickly
softens up
zeke would eventually meet with aaron in
liberia while the latter is infiltrating
marley
he notes how similar in appearance aaron
looks compared to their father
he mentions to aaron that he knows the
details behind the ackermann clan
lineage
and reveals it to him finally zeke tells
aaron of his plan to euthanize the
eldian race
and asks him if he will support it by
using the powers of the founding titan
to render all aldians
sterile after a moment zeke is relieved
to hear aaron
agreeing to help sharing his belief that
grisha's strategy was a mistake
zeke agrees to meet with aaron within
shiganshina district and gives aaron a
baseball in lieu of a handshake
to symbolize their agreement later on
zeke arrives at the festival
with the warriors for willie tiber's
speech when falco grice asks reiner to
accompany him
zeke allows it since there is still time
before the play begins
just as the show is starting a marley
soldier informs the remaining warriors
that maggath has summoned them
recognizing the soldier as helena in
disguise zeke stays silent
and leads both pique and galliard away
wilson being walked to maggot's apparent
location
the soldier instructs zeke to split off
and go through the front gate which he
does
later on after hearing the battle
between the attack titan the warhammer
titan
and the military zeke transforms into
the beast titan and approaches the
battlefield
while joining the kart and jaw titans
zeke then gives the order to annihilate
the enemy while staring down the survey
core and locking eyes with levi
he provides artillery once more by
launching debris at the soldiers
and nearly gets attacked by two soldiers
but is saved by peak
he has her provide covering fire from
behind as he repels the survey corps
back
he then announces that aaron jaeger is
not his enemy but another soldier from
paradise island is
levi ackerman he calls out to levi and
demands him to come face him again
stating that time is running out shortly
afterwards he notices armin's
transformation
into the colossus titan from the nearby
harbor along with everyone else
while the explosion has everyone
distracted levi seizes his opportunity
and catches zeke by surprise
he then attacks the nape of his titan
successfully causing the beast titan to
fall into a prone position
and is unable to defend itself as levi
immediately throws a bomb into the open
nape
the bomb detonates shocking the other
warriors and the rest of the marley
forces present
with the presumed loss of their most
capable warrior however
zeke survives the attack from levi and
is taken aboard the eldian airship
as he regenerates his severed limbs zeke
converses with both aaron and hanji zoe
when both gabby braun and falco are
brought aboard zeke expresses his
surprise
at seeing them there he then discusses
with hanji that despite a number of
miscalculations
namely the two warrior candidates
sacrifices made during the fight were
worth it to ensure eldea had both the
founding titan and someone with royal
blood
he is now confident that eldea will have
a chance at finally obtaining their
freedom
after the airship arrives at paradise
island zeke is seen with levi
inside of a carriage commenting that the
citizens celebrating in the streets
are ignorant of the true impact of the
assault although levi tries to make
death threats to him
zeke is unperturbed and coolly insists
that levi take him to aaron
levi instead take zeke to the titan
forest
informing him that this is where they
will be staying marveling at the site
zeke asks levi if he can show the trees
to gabby and falco
but is told that it depends on his own
actions while zeke is being guarded
inside of the forest
he explains how he was able to transform
the citizens of rigako
levi is bothered by zeke's nonchalant
explanation
accusing him of having no concern for
human life zeke waves away levi's
criticisms explaining that his loyalty
to marley
would have been questioned if he had not
complied with his orders
changing the subject zeke requests to
know winnie will be able to begin
experimenting with aaron's titan
abilities but levi claims he is not
allowed to answer
zeke claims that it would be unwise to
remain inactive for much longer to which
levi readily agrees
he later asks if there's any wine left
and levi informs him that the soldiers
drank it all
zeke sarcastically mentions that levi
comes up with the worst punishments
as levi walks off zeke sees an
opportunity to escape
and runs into the forest before levi or
any of the soldiers can stop
him zeke lets out a piercing scream this
triggers all of the survey corps
soldiers in the camp
who drank the wine to transform into
titans which fall out of the trees
around levi
confident that levi would not slaughter
his own subordinates
zeke mockingly states that he did not
want to do this but laments that this is
not a proper conflict
regardless he summons three of the newly
created titans and bids farewell to levi
he ponders if the aldians truly
understand the ramifications of their
surprise attack
on liberia and inwardly states that only
he and aaron
truly know the costs zeke is stunned to
see a bloodied and angered levi
appear in front of him zeke frantically
orders two of his titans to attack him
and then subsequently transforms into
the beast
titan he immediately hardens his own
nape
and scans the area for levi finding him
zeke tears apart the final surviving
titan
and throws the bloody titan pieces
towards his foe he chastises levi
for killing his subordinate and notices
many tree branches falling towards him
zeke is unable to spot levi among the
branches and is struck by several
thunderspheres that pierce through the
hardened nape of the beast titan
horrified he only has a moment to
process this before levi detonates the
spears
severely injuring zeke sometime later
zeke awakens
tied up on a carriage with a
thunderspear sticking out of his abdomen
levi informs him that the fuse and
triggering mechanism
are tied around his neck and any sudden
movements can set it off
while zeke vomits uncontrollably levi
begins to slice off zeke's legs to
prevent him from transforming
only half conscious zeke asks where his
glasses are
before having his memories of saber
flash before his eyes zeke mutters about
his plan to euthanize the eldean nation
to ensure the world's safety
levi mocks him for this declaring that
his impending death at the hands of a
titan
is too merciful for the lives he has
taken zeke weakly protests that he was
saving their potential children's lives
by killing them
prompting levi to angrily prepare to cut
off his legs again
suddenly zeke screams out saver's name
and jerks back his head pulling the pin
on the thunderspear lodge in his stomach
causing an explosion
the explosion leaves zeke completely
mutilated and his wounds
too severe for his body to regenerate
from as he begins to succumb to his
injuries
zeke recalls a meeting he had with aaron
in which the two of them agreed to
sterilize the eldean race
as zeke loses consciousness one of the
titans he created
regenerates and approaches his body
rather than devour him the titan tears
open its own stomach and places him
inside
zeke regains consciousness to find
himself alone in an unknown location
surprised to discover that he is somehow
still alive
he notices a lone girl silently
reconstructing his body
out of soil as this occurs zeke looks
above him and notices strange patterns
in the sky
he theorizes that he has experienced a
path that the girl before him
is his ancestor ymir fritz after a short
time
zeke is released from the titan's
stomach fully healed from his injuries
and in a slight daze he watches on as
his soldiers pursue hanji before being
approached by a number of jaegerists
with flock forster
trying to ask him what happened
recomposing himself
zika voids his question and merely
proclaims that they just have to move
forward
before departing with the jaegerists
zeke arrives in qigong china to find the
district under siege for marley's forces
and aaron
locked in combat with reiner zeke
launches debris which knocks reiner off
aaron and commends his younger brother
for standing against marley's forces
comforting him that he will now take
care of the enemies
zeke throws a barrage of stones which
destroy at least some
of the marlene airships before turning
his focus towards peak
and mageth after the marlands begin to
fall back he spots reiner charging at
aaron and proceeds to bombard the
armored titan
as well as gallard when he tries to
ambush aaron zeke begins to gloat
about how close he and aaron are to
achieving their dream
but is silenced after spotting the
charred remains of the kart titan
believing peak to have perished in the
attack he mourns his former comrade's
death
he is caught off guard by the sight of
several marlene soldiers
emerging near the cart titan to attack
before zeke can react
maggoth fires around from the anti-titan
artillery
atop the kart titan's corpse damaging
his titan's nape
incapacitated by this zeke plummets off
the wall and crashes into the ground
as zeke comes to his senses he sees
aaron grappling with reiner and
announces to his brother that he will
transform the soldiers who have ingested
his spinal fluid
struggling to get to his feet zeke is
about to unleash a scream
when he notices both colt and falco
arrive at his location
zeke is shocked to hear from colt that
falco accidentally ingested his spinal
fluid
and begs him to refrain from screaming
until falco can safely get out of range
of the scream
dismayed at falco's predicament zeke
gives his condolences to cult
and remarks how he understands that his
former comrade merely wants to protect
his younger brother
despite this zeke ignores colt's request
and lets out a scream
triggering all the affected aldians to
transform into pure titans
seeing aaron struggling to get away from
reiner zeke orders a newly transformed
falco
to fight reiner and kill him after
giving the command
zeke is subsequently shot by magnets
anti-titan artillery a second time
exiting their titans zeke crawls towards
aaron and reaches out to his brother
however before the two can reach each
other aaron is decapitated by a blast
from an anti-titan rifle
fired by gabby aaron's head lands in
zeke's outstretched hand
allowing him to activate the founding
titan before aaron can die from his
injuries
zeke waits in chains until aaron finally
arrives informing his confused younger
brother
that they are inside the coordinate as
ymir fritz approaches them
zeke explains her presence to aaron
theorizing that she uses the sand in the
coordinate to create the nine titans and
heal their users bodies when they are
injured
zeke encourages aaron to command ymir to
begin their euthanasia plan
but aaron first asks about zeke's chains
zeke claims that the chains are what
kept carl fritz's descendants from
acting freely
to zeke's despair aaron reveals that he
has no intention of following the
euthanasia plan
and was only using his brother as a
means to activate the founder
heartbroken zeke reveals to aaron that
he freed himself from fritz's vow while
waiting for aaron and that ymir will
only obey a person with royal blood
chaining aaron zeke laments that aaron
has been brainwashed by grisha
but promises to save him despite aaron's
protests
zeke began showing him their father's
memories as the brothers systematically
observe grisha's memories of his time on
paradise
zeke bitterly notes how seemingly easy
it was for grisha to move on to a new
family
and forget about his old one he shows
aaron how grisha used his occupation as
a doctor
to socialize with nobles to try and gain
information on the royal family
despite the risk such actions would pose
for his family
zeke himself is surprised to learn that
grisha apparently delayed his mission
upon discovering the reese family's
chapel out of love for his new family
coldly admitting
that grisham might have learned from his
failure with zeke
to seek shock his musings are
interrupted by a scene of grisha
seemingly trying to apologize
to his first son in his sleep the two
brothers continue their journey through
grisha's
memories with zeke admitting that aaron
was evidently
not brainwashed by grisha in light of
this zeke questions aaron on why he
betrayed him and what he had planned to
do
with the founder's power aaron answers
by stating he had always been this way
and that what the pitiful brother zeke
had wished for does not exist in him
despite this zeke promises to save aaron
by opening his eyes to the danger eldia
presents
deciding to do this before saving the
world with his euthanasia plan
zeke and aaron eventually arrive at the
date grisha steals the founding titan
from frida at the reese chapel while
watching the memory play out
zeke notices aaron's face distorted with
rage at listening to king fritz's
ideology and is later astonished when
grisha explains the attack
titan's ability to peer into its future
inheritor's memories
zika shocked once more when grisha finds
himself unable to kill the rhys family
confused as to whether the past had
changed his shock quickly turns to angst
however when aaron begins talking to
their father encouraging him to fight
outside of the chapel grisha faintly
aware of zeke's presence
despairingly reveals to him that the
future will not go his way
but errands however he tells zeke
that when seeing one of aaron's memories
from the future what he saw was
terrible grisha becomes fully aware of
zeke's presence
and emotionally embraces him expressing
regret that he was a poor father
and still loves him grisha ends by
pleading zeke to stop
aaron in the unknown land zeke breaks
away from aaron
and looks at him with horror while
processing the fact that aaron
had been the one to push grisha to fight
and had shown certain memories to their
father in order to manipulate him
aaron thanks zeke for allowing him
access to grisha's path
thereby enabling the future he had seen
within his father's memories to occur
terrified zeke orders ymir fritz to
steal the ability to reproduce
from the subjects of ymir as she begins
working towards the pillar of light
zeke tells aaron that grisha had wished
to stop him when aaron escapes his
chains after a struggle
zeke says that it is pointless as once
ymir begins to move
nothing is capable of stopping her aaron
embraces ymir
and begs her to help him end the world
with her power he is even more alarmed
when he sees that yamir has stopped
moving and frantically tries to reach
his brother and yamir
repeatedly ordering ymir to obey his
previous command
stating that he has descended from royal
blood however
before he can reach them ymir agrees to
help aaron activating the rumbling
upon aaron's transformation zeke is
evidently eaten and loses control of his
body
what remains of his being is left alone
in paths until he is joined by armin
arlert who had met a similar fate
after confronting aaron's founding titan
armin sits with zeke
and listens as zeke explains his theory
about the origin of life
zeke theorizes that all life forms and
their meaning by multiplying
and that it was a resultant of fear of
death which caused the amir to spawn an
undying titan body
and escape to the world of the path zeke
theorizes
that the reason she continued to obey
the fritz family for two thousand years
was because she still felt a connection
to the world and that she likely chose
to help aaron
because he was the first person able to
understand her
armin tries to get zeke to tell him how
to escape the path world but zeke
believes there's no point in continuing
to fight
armin reminds the man that their allies
are fighting for the lives of innocent
people but zeke points out that every
living thing
must die eventually armin begins
recalling memories from his childhood
which brought meaning to his life
despite their insignificance
zeke looks up and is startled to see
armin holding a baseball
taking it from him zeke recalls the
times he would play catch with saver
and admits that the time was indeed
precious for him
he muses that he would like to play
catch again even if the game
did not mean anything turning zeke sees
the former titan inheritors
standing behind him including his father
and saver
he stands to meet them admitting to
saver that even though he still thinks
their euthanasia plane was right
he would not mind being born again if it
meant they could play catch again
he thanks grisha for his life and asks
the two father figures to lend him their
strength
ziki merges from aaron's titan and
begins calling for levi
after getting his attention zeke takes a
moment to admire the day
and laments that he did not notice its
beauty sooner
he riley admits that he did not deserve
to notice given the atrocities he has
committed
before being decapitated by levi
thank you so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us
we will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos